The the Sean you'll never guess what we're gonna do today. Are we gonna record an episode? Did I just guess it right? Well first, man, how many times? Baby steps. First thing we're gonna do
肖恩，你绝对猜不到我们今天要做什么。我们要录一集节目吗？我猜对了吗？好吧，伙计，多少次了？一步一个脚印。我们要做的第一件事
is we're gonna welcome our audience and we're gonna say. Oh, welcome to Smartlist. Try to do it in time. Okay, sorry, one more time. One, two, three, on three. One, two, three. No to do it in time. Okay, sorry. One more time. One, two, three, and three. No, the moment's gone. Welcome to Smart List.
就是欢迎我们的听众，我们要说。哦，欢迎来到Smartless。试着同步说出来。好吧，抱歉，再来一次。一，二，三，数到三。一，二，三。没同步。好吧，抱歉。再来一次。一，二，三，数到三。不，时机错过了。欢迎来到Smartless。
Smart List. Smart List. Smart List. Speaking of hydrating, did you run six miles yet today, Babin? No, no. It'll be after this. I didn't think so. Just looking at you, I didn't think so. I'm holding a little water right now, yeah.
Smartless。Smartless。Smartless。说到补水，你今天跑了六英里了吗，巴宾？没有，没有。录完这个再去。我就知道。看你一眼我就知道了。我现在正喝着点水呢，是的。
It's going to be after this session. So I got real tight. I got a hard out in 55 minutes I was on my I was boxing today I did my you know I'm doing this this thing boxing at home I mean I know listen it's a tough guy thing obviously you box at home like in your garage yeah like just with boxes like I'm just putting boxes together beautiful what did you think I meant do you don't really have you're not one of those dorks
录完这期节目就去。所以我时间很紧。我55分钟后必须得走，我今天去练拳击了，你知道我一直在做这个，在家练拳击。我是说，听着，这显然是个硬汉行为，你在车库里练拳击，就像……是的，就像对着箱子练。我只是把箱子堆在一起，很棒。你以为我指的是什么？你真的不是那种书呆子吧？
with a heavy bag hanging in your garage. Ew, that's gross. Do you really have one? It's not hanging, it's on a stand. I got one of these things. He's on the ground, he just tackles it. Thoreau talked me into it. And then you look at Thoreau's arms,
车库里挂着个沙袋。咦，真恶心。你真的有一个吗？不是挂着的，是放在架子上的。我有那种东西。他在地上，他直接扑上去。索罗说服我买的。然后你看看索罗的手臂，
he's on the cover of Esquire, Justin Thoreau, thank you. Why haven't we had Justin on the show yet? Because we wanna talk about him more. We haven't talked about him enough on the show to then have him on. I met him like once or twice, such a nice guy, but I don't know him like you guys do, I would love to. Well, Will, which one of us,
他上了《时尚先生》的封面，贾斯汀·索罗，谢谢。为什么我们还没请贾斯汀上节目？因为我们想多聊聊他。我们在节目里还没聊够他，所以还没请他来。我见过他一两次，人非常好，但我没你们那么了解他，我很想请他来。好吧，威尔，我们之中哪一个，
they can't really be surprised. One of us has gotta. Well, one of us is gonna get on it and the other one's gonna be surprised that the other one did it first. Look, anyway, we gotta get to our guest. Our guest is an incredible writer, performer. Started as a performer, became a writer, then started becoming a performer again.
他们肯定不会感到惊讶。我们之中得有一个人。好吧，我们之中有一个人会去联系，另一个人会惊讶于对方先做了。看，不管怎样，我们得请出我们的嘉宾了。我们的嘉宾是一位了不起的作家、表演者。从表演者起步，成为作家，然后又开始成为表演者。
And the second I mention, one of the things you're gonna be like, I know exactly who this is. We've talked a lot over the episodes with people who've been on SNL. We haven't had anybody who's been on the anchor desk. This person was on the anchor desk for many you. You can't say anything and then not know that it's Tina. Hi. Wait, are you in, is that an outside area of your apartment that I never saw the outside area?
我一提名字，你们就会说，我知道这人是谁。我们在节目里和很多上过《周六夜现场》（SNL）的人聊过。我们还没请过任何坐过主播台的人。这位嘉宾在主播台坐了很久。你不能什么都不说，然后让人猜不到是蒂娜。嗨。等等，你在你公寓的户外区域吗？我从来没见过那个户外区域？
No, I have a weekend home now since the last I saw you, Sean. There's no apartments in the Hudson Valley. No, she weekends in the Hudson Valley. This is, yeah, this is her weekend home. It's my weekend home. Tina, do you and I have the exact same frames? I think yours look black and white. Mine look a little tortoisey. And can I tell you something?
不，自从上次见你之后，肖恩，我现在有个周末度假屋。哈德逊河谷没有公寓。不，她在哈德逊河谷过周末。这是，是的，这是她的周末度假屋。这是我的周末度假屋。蒂娜，你和我的眼镜框是一模一样的吗？我觉得你的看起来是黑白的。我的看起来有点玳瑁色。我能告诉你一件事吗？
Just so you know, like, something, what I'm dealing with here, there's an incredibly passive aggressive nine-year-old out here with me who will not vacate the area. Really? And she's playing some basketball which is like shoot this is probably the first day in her life that she's chosen to play some basketball and it's during this podcast. But that's okay it's a great here comes it's great ambient sound. Incoming incoming. It's great ambient sound. So Tina so Tina tell me what so yes we've all been at home
你要知道，我这里正在处理一些事情，有个极其被动攻击的九岁小孩跟我在一起，她就是不肯离开这个区域。真的吗？她在打篮球，这可能是她人生中第一次选择打篮球，而且偏偏是在录播客的时候。但没关系，这很棒，听，这环境音很棒。来了，来了。这环境音很棒。所以蒂娜，所以蒂娜告诉我，是的，我们都待在家里
for the last year or some version of home or in one of our many homes. One of our many, many homes. So relatable. But do you, so what does that mean for you right now, getting back to it? Because you're always, I always feel like you're always, I know you've just created a new show.
过去一年里，或者某种形式的家，或者在我们众多的家之一。我们众多的，众多的家之一。真有共鸣。但是，这对你来说意味着什么，重新开始？因为你总是，我总觉得你总是，我知道你刚创作了一个新节目。
Yeah. Right, that's about to start Yeah, well, I just we have a I produced a show It's called girls five ever that comes out on peacock on May 6th. It's called girls five ever Yeah, and it's a comedy. It's super funny and it's got it. It starts you out with a laugh. There we go About a bunch of women who were in sort of a Danity Kane level girl group around 2000 and then their song gets sampled now and they're like, should we? We're all 40. We should get our band back together, right?
是的。对，马上就要开始了。是的，我刚制作了一个节目，叫《Girls5eva》，5月6日在孔雀（Peacock）平台上线。叫《Girls5eva》。是的，这是一部喜剧。超级好笑，而且它。它一开始就让你大笑。就是这样。关于一群女性，她们在2000年左右是一个丹妮蒂·凯恩（Danity Kane）级别的女子组合，然后她们的歌现在被采样了，她们就想，我们要不要？我们都40岁了。我们应该重组乐队，对吧？
And it stars. It's a good idea. It's really funny. Yeah, it's really funny. It's Meredith Cardino is the creator on it and it stars Sara Bareilles who is a delight and her voice is ridiculous and she's incredible and also she's like a lovely natural actress and then Renee Elise Goldsberry Who you know from oh, I don't know fucking Hamilton will Jesus You get the look off your face saying that you saying that cuz I'm the only for so long I was the only person who hadn't seen it and it was my badge of honor
而且主演是。这是个好主意。真的很好笑。是的，真的很好笑。梅雷迪思·卡迪诺是创作者，主演是萨拉·巴瑞勒斯，她是个开心果，她的嗓音太离谱了，她太不可思议了，而且她还是个可爱的自然派演员，还有蕾妮·伊莉斯·高德斯伯里，你知道她来自，哦，我不知道，该死的《汉密尔顿》。威尔，天哪。你听到这个名字时脸上的表情，你说那个，因为我是唯一一个，很长一段时间以来我是唯一一个没看过它的人，那曾是我的荣誉勋章。
because I was like, I want to see a fucking musical. Stop telling me it's so great. It's a musical. I get it. And did you? I did see it. It was great. Yeah, it was great. Yeah, it was great. I was wrong. And then wait, let me tell you the other two ladies. Busy Phillips?
因为我当时想，我才不想看什么该死的音乐剧。别再告诉我它有多棒了。它就是个音乐剧。我懂了。那你看了吗？我看了。真的很棒。是的，真的很棒。是的，真的很棒。我错了。等等，让我告诉你另外两位女士。比茜·菲利普斯？
Sure. And American treasure Paula Pell. Oh, she's the best. Oh my God, Paula Pell, we were just talking about Paula Pell. So Paula Pell was a writer on Center Night Live forever and not now, but always kind of an actress, but people are finally recognizing her.
当然。还有美国瑰宝保拉·佩尔。哦，她是最好的。天哪，保拉·佩尔，我们刚才还在聊保拉·佩尔。所以保拉·佩尔曾是《周六夜现场》的长期编剧，现在不是了，但她一直算是个演员，人们终于开始认可她了。
So that's great that you cleared it. Yeah, well she's sort of, you know, we always joke with Paula that she finally aged into her type because she was always the kid at like 12 years old. She was in the play with gray spray in her hair. And that's hilarious. And now she's like, she's her actual type now.
所以你澄清了这一点真好。是的，好吧，她算是，你知道，我们总是和保拉开玩笑说，她终于老成了她适合的类型，因为她总是像12岁的小孩。她在戏里头发上喷着灰色的喷雾。那太搞笑了。现在她就像，她现在就是她真实的类型了。
Gray spray acting. Yeah, Paulina's just reeked of gray spray for 30 years of her life. Sure. So Tina, we have to do this because, but for you it's, you know, obviously you hate going back over like oh this is what I did, but it's interesting to everybody who listens and it's super interesting to us because Not to embarrass you, but you're such a fucking huge
灰色喷雾表演。是的，保琳娜30年来一直散发着灰色喷雾的味道。当然。所以蒂娜，我们必须得做这个，因为，但对你来说，你知道，显然你讨厌回顾过去，比如“哦，这是我做过的”，但这对每个听众来说都很有趣，对我们来说也超级有趣，因为不是要让你尴尬，但你真的是一个该死的巨大的
Piece of the comedy landscape and have been for so long and you're such an great voice Incredible writer incredible performer you started. Yeah, I've just always, you know, that I'm very fond of you. No, there's no but. I've always been very fond of you and I'm such a huge fan in awe of your talent. You started in, you moved to Chicago in early 90s? I, let me think, yeah, 90, I graduated in 92,
喜剧版图的一部分，而且已经很久了，你是一个如此伟大的声音，不可思议的作家，不可思议的表演者，你开始。是的，我一直，你知道，我非常喜欢你。不，没有“但是”。我一直非常喜欢你，我是你才华的超级粉丝，对你充满敬畏。你开始于，你90年代初搬到芝加哥？我，让我想想，是的，92年，我92年毕业，
spring of 92, I graduated from the University of Virginia, so I think I moved in the fall of 92. I graduated from the University of Virginia. So I think I moved in the fall of nine 1992 Yes, yeah, so you're from Pennsylvania and then you move I know so you moved to Chicago you start second city Yeah So I went to UVA kind of randomly and then I went to Chicago and I started improv Olympic First and class at the second city and that's where I met Amy Poehler Sure, and a bunch of other people that only Amy Poehler and I know. But like Kevin Dorr from Brian Stack and Miriam Toll and all those guys.
92年春天，我从弗吉尼亚大学毕业，所以我认为我是92年秋天搬过去的。我从弗吉尼亚大学毕业。所以我认为我是1992年秋天搬过去的。是的，是的，所以你是宾夕法尼亚人，然后你搬到，我知道，所以你搬到芝加哥，你开始在第二城（Second City）。是的。所以我有点随机地去了弗吉尼亚大学，然后我去了芝加哥，我先开始了即兴奥林匹克（ImprovOlympic），然后在第二城上课，那是我遇见艾米·波勒的地方。当然，还有一堆只有艾米·波勒和我认识的人。但像凯文·多尔、布莱恩·斯塔克、米里亚姆·托尔还有所有那些家伙。
Dratch, Rachel Dratch. Those were your contemporaries. I remember that was kind of your crew, all those people. So is it crazy that like three of those people end up on Saturday Night Live? I mean, the odds of that is crazy. I mean, it is and it isn't, I guess, because well, then at the time, there's like the groundlings, stand-ups the groundlings and second city were the places they looked. Now, you know, the internet has become the great equalizer and you find people on YouTube, you find people on TikTok, presumably.
德拉奇，瑞秋·德拉奇。那是你的同代人。我记得那是你的圈子，所有那些人。所以，那三个人最终都上了《周六夜现场》，这不是很疯狂吗？我的意思是，那样的几率太疯狂了。我的意思是，是也不是，我想，因为当时，有像“地面人”（Groundlings），单口喜剧演员，“地面人”和“第二城”是他们寻找人才的地方。现在，你知道，互联网已经成为了伟大的平衡器，你在YouTube上找到人，你在TikTok上找到人，大概吧。
I'm so surprised they didn't run into you. Yeah, you were a musical director. Well, you didn't run into me because, I don't think, because you were a musical director out in the burbs, right? Yeah, in the burbs, but I was always downtown Chicago, always around the, I had some friends at Second City, I'm just surprised we never had. And the bus station.
我很惊讶他们没碰到你。是的，你是个音乐总监。好吧，你没碰到我，因为，我不认为，因为你是个在郊区的音乐总监，对吧？是的，在郊区，但我总是在芝加哥市中心，总是在周围，我在第二城有一些朋友，我只是很惊讶我们从来没碰到过。还有公交车站。
And each other, the bus station. Wait, so Tina, so those are kind of your peeps. I know that like Dratch and Amy and Stack and Miriam and all those kinds of guys were your yeah and Horatio I got another one on laser like all those kinds of people were there too, right? Like in Chicago. I was glazers understudy I was John glazers under no way. Yeah, and then he left to do Dana Carvey, right? Yes Yeah, that's right. And I got to go onto the main stage when he left, yeah. So then you moved from Chicago to SNL. Like, McKay and those guys were kind of seniors
还有彼此，公交车站。等等，所以蒂娜，所以那些算是你的伙伴。我知道像德拉奇、艾米、斯塔克、米里亚姆和所有那些家伙都是你的，是的，还有霍拉肖，我还有一个在激光表演里，所有那些人也都在那儿，对吧？就像在芝加哥。我是格雷泽的替补，我是约翰·格雷泽的替补。不会吧。是的，然后他离开去做了达纳·卡维的节目，对吧？是的，没错。他离开后我就上了主舞台，是的。所以你从芝加哥搬到了《周六夜现场》。像麦凯那些家伙算是前辈
when you guys were freshmen. Is that kind of the idea? Adam McKay, yeah. Exactly. Adam McKay was already head writer at SNL, and I submitted my writer's packet to him, because I had been on stage at Second City, and Lorne Michaels and Marcy Klein had come to scout talent and zero interest in me as
当你们是新人的时候。是这个意思吗？亚当·麦凯，是的。完全正确。亚当·麦凯已经是《周六夜现场》的首席编剧了，我把我的编剧作品集提交给了他，因为我曾在第二城的舞台上表演过，洛恩·迈克尔斯和玛西·克莱恩曾来物色人才，但对我作为
a performer so I was like well writer's packet it is and just for people who don't know Adam McKay was Will Ferrell's business partner and writer of SNL and writer of all these amazing movies and then he directs crazy huge movies now and yeah now he directs a lot of dramatic movies. He's an Oscar winner now guys. Yeah yeah but also for Wisconsin there is a you can either be a performer or a writer on Saturday Night Live. And sometimes you make the leap you get hired as a writer like Sudeikis I remember Sudeikis this first year was a writer. Yeah Sudeikis was a writer did not want to be a writer.
表演者毫无兴趣，所以我当时想，好吧，那就投编剧作品集吧。对于那些不知道的人，亚当·麦凯是威尔·法瑞尔的商业伙伴，《周六夜现场》的编剧，所有这些精彩电影的编剧，现在他导演了疯狂的大制作电影，是的，现在他导演了很多剧情片。伙计们，他现在是奥斯卡得主了。是的，是的，但对于威斯康星州来说，你可以在《周六夜现场》做表演者或编剧。有时你会跨界，你被聘为编剧，比如苏戴奇斯，我记得苏戴奇斯第一年是编剧。是的，苏戴奇斯是编剧，但他不想做编剧。
Conan was a writer. The best part about Sudeikis was a writer. Did not want to be a writer. Conan was a writer. The best part about Sudeikis being a writer and not wanting to be a writer was that he let everybody know. So, in the best way, in the best way. Sina, were you one of those people that always dreamed of being on Saturday Night Live? Because I hear so many alums saying, oh, when I was a kid, all I ever wanted. And then they get there and then their dream comes true and they're on Saturday Night Live. Yeah, it is. I feel like I so wanted to be on Saturday Night Live that to me I would like it would be hard for me to understand meeting anyone who didn't want to do that. Right, right. Yeah.
柯南曾是编剧。苏戴奇斯做编剧最棒的部分是，他不想做编剧。柯南曾是编剧。苏戴奇斯做编剧且不想做编剧最棒的部分是，他让所有人都知道了。所以，以最好的方式，以最好的方式。蒂娜，你是那种一直梦想着上《周六夜现场》的人吗？因为我听到很多校友说，哦，当我还是个孩子的时候，我唯一想要的。然后他们到了那里，梦想成真了，他们上了《周六夜现场》。是的，确实。我觉得我太想上《周六夜现场》了，对我来说，很难理解怎么会有人不想做那个。对，对。是的。
What do you mean you don't want to do that? And then were you disappointed that they didn't that they didn't select you for the performing part or were you more comfortable writing anyway? I was always a bit more of a writer even the way I contributed to the company at Second City, I definitely was an idea person. I wasn't someone, I didn't have that magic thing that Horatio Sanz or Rachel Dratch have where they come out and you're just like, oh, this is going to be good. Like they just sparkly, you know? Don't you feel like to a certain extent, like you kind of I don't know this is gonna sound mean for performers
你是什么意思，你不想做那个？然后你是否因为他们没有选你做表演部分而感到失望，还是你本来就更适应写作？我一直更偏向于写作，即使在第二城我对公司的贡献方式，我绝对是个点子人。我不是那种，我没有霍拉肖·桑兹或瑞秋·德拉奇那种魔力，他们一出来你就觉得，哦，这会很棒。就像他们闪闪发光，你知道吗？你不觉得在某种程度上，你有点，我不知道这听起来对表演者会不会很刻薄
But you're kind of overqualified to be a performer like it's really hard to be a writer I think really hard to be a director less less hard to be an actor because Everybody does that every day anyway, whether you're an actor or not I mean people change their behavior when they're with their grandmother versus their best friend. Like, people know how to adjust the way in which they come across. Like, that's acting.
但你作为表演者有点大材小用了，我觉得做编剧真的很难，做导演也很难，做演员没那么难，因为每个人每天都在做，不管你是不是演员。我的意思是，人们在祖母面前和在最好的朋友面前表现出的行为是不一样的。人们知道如何调整自己的表现方式，那也是表演。
But writing, I feel like that's really difficult stuff. Yeah, I mean, I think it's more work, the writing and directing. It is like, people who are really good actors, listen, acting is like 99% having a good face. It doesn't have to be a beautiful face. It's like an interesting face. It could be, you know what I mean? It could be Lupita Nyong'o, it could be Steve Buscemi, but you got to have a face that people want to look at. And that's like 99% of it. And then the other like then 0.4% beyond that is talent.
但写作，我觉得那是真的很难的东西。是的，我的意思是，我觉得写作和导演更费力。就像，真正优秀的演员，听着，表演就像99%靠一张好脸。不一定非得是漂亮的脸。它是一张有趣的脸。可以是，你知道我的意思吗？可以是露皮塔·尼永奥，可以是史蒂夫·布西密，但你得有一张人们想看的脸。那占了99%。然后剩下的0.4%是天赋。
But I think you have that. I think, you know, what you were saying about Horatio and Rachel, you have that thing too where you come out and people are like, oh my God, that's gonna be so good. Because it's you, it's Tina Fey. It was always fucking funny and always delivers. So I think people get just as excited.
但我认为你有那个。我认为，你知道，关于霍拉肖和瑞秋你说的那些，你也有那种特质，你一出来人们就觉得，哦天哪，那会很棒。因为是你，是蒂娜·菲。总是该死的有趣，总是能带来惊喜。所以我认为人们也会同样兴奋。
That's very kind of, I think now, I think I've like slowly worn people down. I think it's been like, it's mirrored my dating life in every way. I'm just like, I'll wear people down. I think it's been like, it's mirrored my dating life in every way. I'm just like, I'll wear you down. But Tina, you gotta admit, like in the best way, like you kinda Trojan horse them, like Marcy and Lauren come in and they sort of like,
你太客气了，我想现在，我想我已经慢慢磨平了人们的棱角。我想这就像，它在各方面都映射了我的约会生活。我只是，我会磨平人们的棱角。我想这就像，它在各方面都映射了我的约会生活。我只是，我会磨平你的棱角。但是蒂娜，你得承认，以最好的方式，你有点像特洛伊木马，玛西和洛恩进来，他们有点像，
okay, and they don't even see you or whatever. And then you come and you submit your packet. Obviously, McKay wants, he knows how brilliant you are. You come, you start submitting on SNL, and then your talent just shows through, and you end up getting it in spite of them and become like the biggest star on the show for many years. That's gotta feel kind of gratifying.
好吧，他们甚至没看到你什么的。然后你来了，你提交了你的作品集。显然，麦凯想要，他知道你有多聪明。你来了，你开始在《周六夜现场》投稿，然后你的才华就显露出来了，你最终在他们意料之外得到了机会，并成为了节目多年来最大的明星。那一定感觉很满足。
I don't mean that in a shitty way, but it must feel like, yeah, I always knew I could do this in a real way. It was, you know, yeah, the long grift sort of paid off. I mean, there's a couple factors. There's like the team of gay scientists that fixed my appearance. That's the title of your next series, by the way. And then like, I always say don't underestimate how gloriously lazy Lorne is about casting because this is like Conan like do you think someone was like going all over town being like where's a
我不是以那种糟糕的方式说的，但那一定感觉像，是的，我一直知道我能以真正的方式做到这一点。那是，你知道，是的，长期的骗局算是成功了。我的意思是，有几个因素。就像那个修复我外貌的同性恋科学家团队。顺便说一句，那是你下一部剧的标题。然后就像，我总是说不要低估洛恩在选角上有多么光荣的懒惰，因为这就像柯南，你觉得有人会满城跑着说，哪里有个
Pasty seven foot redhead that we can put then we can give a talk show to it's like no He was around the office being funny around the office and that's the same thing happened here It was like we need to new update anchors. Like, let me look inside my own eyelids for like who's available. Do you prefer one over the other, acting and writing? Like, do you miss performing when you're not in a writer's room and vice versa? Writing is like, it's only fun to have written something.
苍白的七英尺红发男，我们可以给他一个脱口秀节目？不，他在办公室周围很有趣，这就是这里发生的事情。就像我们需要新的更新主播。让我看看我自己的眼皮底下谁有空。你更喜欢哪一个，表演还是写作？比如，当你不在编剧室时，你会想念表演吗，反之亦然？写作就像，只有写完东西才有趣。
Like, writing's only fun after it's over. And performing is like fun after it's over. And performing is like fun while it's happening. And then for me, if you're me, you usually look back after and go, oh, yeah, that wasn't. Yeah, that would include myself. I would include myself in that. Do you think that? Yeah. Yeah, no, I would just like, like, I'm beat myself up all the time. Well, you're crazy.
就像，写作只有在结束后才有趣。表演就像在结束后才有趣。表演就像在进行时很有趣。然后对我来说，如果你是我，你通常会在事后回顾说，哦，是的，那不是。是的，我会把自己包括在内。你觉得吗？是的。是的，不，我只是会，就像，我总是会自我批评。好吧，你疯了。
So it is common for the weekend anchor to not be a performer, correct? Yeah. Well, Chevy was first, right? He was mostly just that. He was not a performer that much on the show, was he? Not too much. He was a little bit. He did Gerald Ford and some commercials. Is it common for the head writer to be the anchor? It is now, because Joe Stinche are the head writers, I think, among like. And Seth as well was, yes?
所以周末主播不是表演者是很常见的，对吧？是的。好吧，切维是第一个，对吧？他大部分时间只是那样。他在节目里不是那么多的表演者，是吗？不多。他有一点。他模仿了杰拉尔德·福特和一些广告。首席编剧做主播很常见吗？现在是了，因为乔·斯廷奇是首席编剧，我想，在像。还有塞斯也是，对吧？
Seth was, yes, yeah. You know what I really did learn that time too, is that I learned, you know, after Jimmy left, and then Lauren was like, well, do you wanna do it by yourself? And I thought like, well, I'm supposed to want to do it by myself, right? And I think we even did like that.
塞斯是，是的，是的。你知道我那段时间真的学到了什么吗，我学到了，你知道，吉米离开后，然后洛恩说，好吧，你想一个人做吗？我想，好吧，我应该想一个人做，对吧？我想我们甚至做了那个。
And then at the last minute, I was like, I don't want to. I want to do it with Amy. And I realized that's what I learned. I don't work a single. Right. Yeah, I kind of remember that. I remember that first. That was a very late breaking decision.
然后在最后一刻，我当时想，我不想。我想和艾米一起做。我意识到那就是我学到的。我不做单人。对。是的，我有点记得那个。我记得那个第一次。那是一个非常晚才做出的决定。
Very late. Rudely late. And then it turned out to be obviously great. And you guys, that was such a exciting time for the show you guys were so good and it was so much fun and it was fun to have a front-row seat to that it was amazing and then you guys at that kind of right in that same year you guys were doing Mean Girls at the same time that first you started right you guys were shooting while you were doing update remember that it was crazy
非常晚。粗鲁地晚。然后结果显然很棒。你们，那对节目来说是一个非常激动人心的时刻，你们太棒了，而且非常有趣，能坐在前排看那个真是太棒了，然后你们在同一年，你们同时在做《贱女孩》，记得吗？你们在做更新的时候在拍摄，记得吗？那太疯狂了。
maybe I think you're probably I'm to assume that you're right about that. So many things, I drag to trash. I don't remember a lot of things. Drag to trash. That's the name of my biography. But that seems right. Tina, are you still a fan of SNL? Of course you are. I'm sure you are.
也许，我想你可能，我假设你关于那个是对的。太多事情了，我拖着垃圾。我不记得很多事情。拖着垃圾。那是我的传记的名字。但这似乎是对的。蒂娜，你还是《周六夜现场》的粉丝吗？当然是。我肯定你是。
Is there anybody that you just are completely drawn to that's on now that you're like, want to work with or? Oh yeah, well that's, I am a fan and what's really exciting now is my older daughter Alice is 15 and so we stay up and watch together so that's fun to like be at that age with her where she's into it, you know. And yeah, I mean.
有没有谁是你完全被吸引的，现在在节目里的，你觉得想和他们合作或者？哦是的，好吧，那是，我是粉丝，现在真正令人兴奋的是我的大女儿爱丽丝15岁了，所以我们熬夜一起看，所以能和她在这个年龄一起看她感兴趣的东西很有趣，你知道。而且是的，我的意思是。
Does she go back and watch your episodes? No. No. No. Do your kids wanna watch your stuff? No, they don't give it up. My kids, my wife, no one thinks I'm doing anything they don't give it up the my kids my wife? No one thinks I'm doing anything but counting paper clips when I'm healthy though. That's healthy. I think yeah
她会回去看你的剧集吗？不。不。不。你的孩子想看你的东西吗？不，他们不买账。我的孩子，我的妻子，没人觉得我在做什么，他们不买账，我的孩子，我的妻子？没人觉得我在做什么，除了在健康的时候数回形针。那很健康。我想是的。
And they watch everything they've what like you watch Parks and Rec 100% yeah the office 100% yeah, yeah exactly But so yeah, I mean I'm still a fan of Kenan That's never gonna change. I think Chris Redd is super funny. Yeah, Chris Redd. Chris Redd, Chris Redd was on Will and Grace and he was supposed to be a recurring character. And as they were trying to make his deal, he got a call like a week later. And like a week or two later, he's on Saturday Night Live.
他们看一切，他们看《公园与游憩》100%，是的，《办公室》100%，是的，是的，完全正确。但所以，是的，我的意思是，我仍然是基南的粉丝。那永远不会改变。我觉得克里斯·雷德超级有趣。是的，克里斯·雷德。克里斯·雷德，克里斯·雷德曾上过《威尔和格蕾丝》，他本应是一个常驻角色。当他们试图达成协议时，他一周后接到了电话。大约一周或两周后，他就上了《周六夜现场》。
He's like, that's so crazy. He just did like a couple episodes of Will and Grace. That is crazy. So Tina, how do you manage being so great at what it is that you do? Like how do you decide where to point your work? I mean, you can do so many different things, whether it's television or film or theater, musicals,
他说，那太疯狂了。他只是做了几集《威尔和格蕾丝》。那太疯狂了。所以蒂娜，你是怎么管理自己做得这么好的？比如你是怎么决定把工作重心放在哪里的？我的意思是，你可以做很多不同的事情，无论是电视、电影还是戏剧、音乐剧，
on camera, behind camera. I would imagine it would be somewhat burdensome to try to figure out what to prioritize. I mean, I think TV's sort of where I'm most comfortable, because I feel like it's the most interesting place right now. There's more interesting things happening in TV, especially for comedy.
台前，幕后。我想试图弄清楚优先考虑什么会是一种负担。我的意思是，我想电视是我最舒服的地方，因为我觉得那是现在最有趣的地方。电视里有更多有趣的事情发生，尤其是喜剧。
I feel like the movies is kind of glacially paced. And it's not that I don't wanna do movies, but it also just feels like there's so many more chances for people to fuck it up in movies. Well, it takes seven years to make a movie. Yeah, it takes seven years and it takes seven years to shoot it. Don't you always find that like,
我觉得电影的节奏有点缓慢。并不是说我不想拍电影，但它也感觉在电影里人们搞砸的机会更多。好吧，拍一部电影需要七年。是的，需要七年，拍摄也需要七年。你不觉得总是，
there's nothing more boring in a lot of ways than making a movie and being on a movie set? It's so slow and it's not conducive to that immediacy that you have when you're making a show when you've got to shoot nine pages in a day and you've got to get the scene and you've got to move, it's got to be quick. And that lends itself to being funnier rather than shooting one side of it for one day and then you shoot like three-eighths of a page. Like, it's the worst. And in TV, you know, you did 30 Rock,
在很多方面，拍电影和在电影片场比什么都无聊吗？它太慢了，不利于你在制作节目时拥有的那种即时性，当你一天必须拍九页纸，你必须完成场景，你必须移动，它必须很快。这有助于变得更有趣，而不是一天只拍一边，然后你拍了八分之三页。就像，那是糟糕的。在电视里，你知道，你做了《我为喜剧狂》，
you guys would jam through those, you'd have those huge packed days with just like a million scenes, and you just gotta get it. Also, we all joke about, like, remember when we used to make 22 episodes of things? That's like ridiculous now. Like, everyone makes like three episodes
你们会挤过那些，你们会有那些巨大的忙碌日子，只有一百万个场景，你必须完成它。还有，我们都开玩笑说，记得我们过去制作22集的东西吗？现在那太荒谬了。就像，每个人都制作三集
and collects their awards. Don't you think those days are those days seem like they're over don't you think? The 22 episode day? I think so. Or the 100 episodes of a show. Yeah I think so. What about what about writing writing books was that is that a good time pace for you or is that somewhat glacial as well? I just did that the one time and I remember I was like doing 30 Rock at the one time and I remember I was like doing 30 Rock at the same time. I was doing, I think I started it, I remember I was on the set of Date Night with Steve Carell
然后收集他们的奖项。你不觉得那些日子，那些日子看起来已经结束了吗？你不觉得吗？22集的日子？我想是的。或者一部剧100集。是的，我想是的。写书呢，写书对你来说是一个好的时间节奏吗，还是那也有些缓慢？我只做过那一次，我记得我当时在做《我为喜剧狂》，我记得我当时在做《我为喜剧狂》的同时。我在做，我想我开始了，我记得我在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的《约会之夜》片场，
and I just had like a notebook on so I was like, yeah, I guess I said I would write this book. And then as short as that book is, I felt like it near about killed me because, again, I don't work a single and I was so used to having a writer's room and I was like, not so much that it was more work, but it was just so vulnerable of like,
我只是有一个笔记本，所以我当时想，是的，我想我说过我会写这本书。而且尽管那本书很短，我觉得它差点杀了我，因为，再次强调，我不做单人，我习惯了有编剧室，我当时想，不是说它工作量更大，而是它太脆弱了，就像，
if this book comes out and people are like, boo, it's 100% my fault. It's 100% a rejection of me personally. It's not a novel. It's just like, here's what my deal is and if people were like boo It I've never felt so nervous about anything. I walk into like a grocery store and people go boo. I'm sure Yeah, that's just cuz they've seen your work. That's yeah
如果这本书出来，人们说“嘘”，那100%是我的错。那100%是对我个人的拒绝。它不是小说。它只是，这是我的情况，如果人们说“嘘”，我从来没对任何事情感到这么紧张。我走进杂货店，人们说“嘘”。我肯定。是的，那只是因为他们看过你的作品。那是，是的。
Tina yes, you're good. Go ahead. Are you in like a Old person's bathroom. What is that? By the way, you should know, you should know. So this is my home booth, and these are actually handles for a bathtub. No joke. Because usually when I record my real VOs, I'm standing up and I like to lean and hold on. So I had the guy get these, and they are for somebody who needs help
蒂娜，是的，你很好。继续。你在像老年人的浴室里吗？那是什么？顺便说一句，你应该知道，你应该知道。这是我的家庭录音棚，这些实际上是浴缸的把手。没开玩笑。因为通常我录制真正的配音时，我是站着的，我喜欢靠着并抓住。所以我让那个人装了这些，它们是为需要帮助的人准备的
getting in and out of a tub. Now, how much harder or what would you have to navigate to become to do what you do today? If you were starting out and you were 22 today and trying to get into comedy, fuck, right? Well, you get, yeah. Advice, right? Not even advice, just like what would you do to yourself?
进出浴缸。现在，要做到你今天所做的事情，你必须克服多少困难？如果你今天22岁，刚开始尝试进入喜剧界，该死，对吧？好吧，你得到，是的。建议，对吧？甚至不是建议，只是，你会对自己做什么？
Like how would you do it if you were graduating? I'm not necessarily saying hey to young writers out there listen. I'm like literally what would you do? Yeah, that's a good question What would I do? I I probably would be trying to blow up on tick-tock or something right? I would be cutting out the middleman Which listen it's worked well in porn sure you have no anymore, right? which, listen, it's worked well in porn. It needs Hugh Hefner anymore, right? Just. Um.
如果你毕业了，你会怎么做？我不一定是在说嘿，年轻的编剧们听着。我真的是在问你会怎么做？是的，这是个好问题。我会怎么做？我可能正试图在TikTok上火起来什么的吧？我会绕过中间商，这听起来，它在色情行业运作得很好，当然你不再需要了，对吧？这，听着，它在色情行业运作得很好。不再需要休·赫夫纳了，对吧？只是。嗯。
It seems like, I mean, unless I'm wrong, it seems like people on TikTok really wanna be in television or film, and the people in television or film aren't making that money anymore, so they wanna go blow up on TikTok. It's, it's, uh. Yeah.
看起来，我的意思是，除非我错了，看起来TikTok上的人真的想进入电视或电影，而电视或电影里的人不再赚那么多钱了，所以他们想去TikTok上火起来。这是，呃。是的。
Don't you feel that way? Yeah, I think broadcast TV especially doesn't mean, like, to my kids, that doesn't mean anything to them like they don't they don't understand What's happening is there still I'm gonna sound like a real old man here. Can you still like make a bunch of money on? Social media like saying I like this kind of chocolate. I I say this cut like Right, that's a whole industry, right? I think so right that's a whole industry right I think so Yeah, like taste the adjustment does not what tastemakers are called is it is that was it influencers influencers right? And like people have agents for that and stuff dude. I think so take yourself out back
你不觉得吗？是的，我觉得广播电视尤其没有意义，就像，对我的孩子来说，那对他们没有任何意义，他们不明白。发生了什么，还有人能赚很多钱吗？社交媒体，比如我说我喜欢这种巧克力。我，我说这个，对，那是一个完整的行业，对吧？我想是的，对，那是一个完整的行业，对吧？我想是的。是的，就像品味调整，不是品味制造者叫什么，是，那是，那是网红，网红对吧？而且人们有经纪人什么的，伙计。我想是的，带自己出去
And just end it man This is fucking by the way This is a great opportunity to mention you said chocolate Jason for us to mention Reese's Jason's been asking me To reach out to the people at Reese's because he wants free peanut butter cups Well, I just think it doesn't make any money over on the Ozarks I but I'm so sick and tired of hearing your dumb voice sell candy on TV Okay, I'm like if I got to listen to it if I got to listen to it, if I got to listen to it, then why don't you get me a free box of those, the peanut butter cups that are wrapped in
然后结束它，伙计。这是该死的，顺便说一句，这是一个很好的机会提到你说的巧克力，杰森，让我们提到瑞茜（Reese's）。杰森一直要求我联系瑞茜的人，因为他想要免费的花生酱杯。好吧，我只是觉得在欧扎克那边赚不到钱。但我厌倦了听到你愚蠢的声音在电视上卖糖果。好吧，我如果必须听它，如果我必须听它，如果我必须听它，那你为什么不给我一盒免费的那些，包裹在
peanut butter with the peanut butter inside. It's double triple peanut butter and I'm not sorry, whatever it is. I need some of that for free for having to listen to your crap. Okay, I got it. I wrote it down and they're obviously listening right now so thank you everybody at Reese's and to Jason Bateman Should I give my address over the year? Number one Deadline Hollywood Way Tina did you ever imagine it would be this amazing being on this podcast? I mean I thought about it
花生酱里，里面有花生酱的。那是双重三重花生酱，我并不抱歉，不管它是什么。我需要一些免费的，因为我不得不听你的废话。好吧，我明白了。我记下来了，他们显然现在正在听，所以谢谢瑞茜的每一个人，还有杰森·贝特曼。我应该在节目里给出我的地址吗？Deadline Hollywood Way。蒂娜，你有没有想过上这个播客会这么棒？我的意思是，我想过
Thought about saying no and then My tip on Reese's though, you know, this is my tip on all candy. Sure. Whenever there's holiday candy, where it's like the Reese's shaped like Santa Claus, always buy that candy because it's fresher. Fresher, nice. Because they just made it. You could get a regular candy bar.
想过说不，然后我关于瑞茜的建议，你知道，这是我关于所有糖果的建议。当然。每当有节日糖果，比如做成圣诞老人形状的瑞茜，总是买那个糖果，因为它更新鲜。更新鲜，不错。因为他们刚做出来。你可以买一个普通的糖果棒。
That's a good point. Could have been in the CVS for seven months. Really good point. We often ask this question of people who are in the public eye who have children. Would you, do your kids want to do what mom and or dad does or do you, would you discourage them from getting it or you just say follow your dreams and I'll support you? It's funny you should ask that. Our older daughter, you know, I think if anything maybe would be interested in directing.
那是个好观点。可能在CVS里放了七个月了。很好的观点。我们经常问那些有孩子的公众人物这个问题。你会，你的孩子想做妈妈或爸爸做的事情吗，或者你，你会劝阻他们进入这个行业，还是你只是说追随你的梦想，我会支持你？你问这个很有趣。我们的大女儿，你知道，我想如果有的话，也许会对导演感兴趣。
I think she would be horrified to perform and And I never like when she was a little kid, I think all little kids think they want to. And I think I let her be it. I think she was in some still photographs Alice, she played young Liz Lemon, but in a series of photographs at the end of the end and end of 30 Rock. And, and that was like, that's enough. Like, let's keep it measured. And then this other one that you that's you you, no, no, what I'm dealing with. During the pandemic, it came up, we were, for Girls 5Eva, we had to cast a kid to play busy Phillips and Andrew Rannell's child,
我想她会因为表演而感到恐惧，而且我从来不喜欢，当她还是个小孩子的时候，我想所有小孩子都认为他们想。我想我让她做了。我想她拍了一些静态照片，爱丽丝，她扮演了年轻的莉兹·莱蒙，但在《我为喜剧狂》结尾的一系列照片中。而且，那已经足够了。就像，让我们保持适度。然后另一个你，你，不，不，我正在处理的。在疫情期间，它出现了，我们，对于《Girls5eva》，我们必须选一个孩子来扮演比茜·菲利普斯和安德鲁·兰内尔的孩子，
who was like a little YouTube villain. And I had always said about that one, I was like, you know what? That's a Nellie, I got a Nellie Olsen right here. Um. I was like, you know what? That's a Nellie. I got a Nellie Olsen right here Jason knows Nellie. I know Small world. She became a stand-up. I believe me. She really I loved her Yeah, I remember like she became a stand-up for a while, right? I want to say Allison
那是一个像小YouTube恶棍的孩子。我一直说那个，我当时想，你知道吗？那是内莉，我这里有个内莉·奥尔森。嗯。我当时想，你知道吗？那是内莉。我这里有个内莉·奥尔森，杰森认识内莉。我知道。小世界。她成了单口喜剧演员。我相信我。她真的，我爱她。是的，我记得她有一段时间成了单口喜剧演员，对吧？我想说是艾莉森
Angrem is that dude if you don't know my god Allison Arngram did I said that I said it right? That's an Arngram. Yeah? Dude, if you don't know! Oh my god. Alison Arngrem. Did I say that? I said it right, right? Alison Arngrem, yeah. Yeah. There you go. Anyway, we... So I let her audition for this part because it was sort of like... Wait, you made your daughter read? Of course I made her read.
安格林，那是伙计，如果你不知道，天哪，艾莉森·安格林，我说了，我说了对吧？那是安格林。是吗？伙计，如果你不知道！天哪。艾莉森·安格林。我说了吗？我说了对吧，对吧？艾莉森·安格林，是的。是的。就是这样。不管怎样，我们……所以我让她试镜这个角色，因为它有点像……等等，你让你女儿读了？我当然让她读了。
Yeah, because I thought that was gonna be the end of it. And then her audition was pretty good. And... I thought I was the bad parent on this set. Oh, it was gonna get worse. And then then we had just and then there were and then you know she did pretty well and then there was another kid who was like an actual experienced kid and we're like well this and I'm and I was like this will be good for her she you know we could hire the kid with more experience and then and so I had to tell her like well
是的，因为我以为那会是结束。然后她的试镜相当不错。而且……我以为我是片场那个糟糕的家长。哦，情况会变得更糟。然后我们刚刚，然后有，然后你知道她做得很好，然后有另一个孩子，像一个真正有经验的孩子，我们当时想，好吧，这个，我当时想，这对她有好处，她，你知道，我们可以雇佣那个更有经验的孩子，然后，所以我不得不告诉她，好吧，
you did really well and I was making it up I. I was like, you were in the top three. And, but you know, we had, and then she was like, basically it was like, I didn't book it. And I was like, you didn't book it. Well, I was like, you're half TFA and that bitch never booked anything. And so I was like, you didn't book it. But then because it was the pandemic,
你做得很好，我是在编造。我当时想，你在前三名。但是你知道，我们有，然后她当时想，基本上就像，我没选上。我当时想，你没选上。好吧，我当时想，你是蒂娜·菲的一半，那个婊子从来没选上过任何东西。所以我当时想，你没选上。但因为是疫情，
this other poor kid, they were like, well, she can work as a local hire, but she's in Michigan right now. And the quarantine, it fell apart. And so then I was like, back up. All right, home girl, you're up. So she's in it. And now we're faced now. And it was at the time it was like, you get to leave the house and get a test and work during quarantine. And I will say she was incredibly professional. I said she was like a little bit like mommy. was like very prepared and a little dead-eyed.
另一个可怜的孩子，他们当时想，好吧，她可以作为本地雇员工作，但她现在在密歇根。隔离，它失败了。所以我当时想，回来。好吧，宝贝，轮到你了。所以她在里面了。现在我们面临，现在。当时就像，你可以离开家，去做个测试，在隔离期间工作。我得说她非常专业。我说她有点像妈妈。非常准备充分，有点眼神空洞。
E-ball acted with me. That's what it is. But she was good. A little dead-eyed. My god, if she hears the clip of that she'll murder me. So listen, Tina, I'm kind of obsessed with horrible theater stories and theater stories gone wrong. I have so many. Do you have like a favorite of like a play you were in or at Second City or something? Oh, a favorite theater horror story?
E-ball和我演对手戏。就是这样。但她很好。有点眼神空洞。天哪，如果她听到那个片段，她会杀了我。所以听着，蒂娜，我有点痴迷于糟糕的戏剧故事和出错的戏剧故事。我有很多。你有像最喜欢的你在戏里，或者在第二城什么的吗？哦，最喜欢的戏剧恐怖故事？
I do have a pretty good theater horror story. This is from high school theater. So okay, in my high school, I played Van Helsing in Dracula because feminism. Did you borrow Paul's gray spray? I probably did. Nice callback. Nice callback. And callback. Thanks.
我确实有一个相当不错的戏剧恐怖故事。这是高中戏剧里的。所以好吧，在我的高中，我在《德古拉》里扮演范海辛，因为女权主义。你借了保罗的灰色喷雾吗？我可能借了。不错的呼应。不错的呼应。还有呼应。谢谢。
Okay, so let me think about this. I was Van Helsing and Dracula and we did a total of two performances and everything went wrong. I can't remember the story. The first thing that kind of went wrong would be like our theater was a thrust stage and the seats went up. Is that arena? Like tiered? was a thrust stage and the seats went up. So like, the stage was on the ground and the audience was up.
好吧，让我考虑一下。我在《德古拉》里扮演范海辛，我们总共演了两场，一切都出错了。我不记得故事了。第一件出错的事情就像我们的剧院是一个伸出式舞台，座位往上走。那是竞技场吗？像分层的？是伸出式舞台，座位往上走。所以，舞台在地上，观众在上面。
And we had like a rubber bat on a very long string. Scene one, the bat's supposed to fly by, the bat gets stuck. It's just dangling on the stage the rest of the night. We're like, oh, that's not good. Then I give some big speech. There's this guy, Harker says to me like, Professor, what is a vampire? And I give a speech like, I give like a page and a half speech of what is a vampire.
我们有一只系在很长绳子上的橡胶蝙蝠。第一场，蝙蝠应该飞过去，蝙蝠卡住了。它就在舞台上晃荡了一整晚。我们当时想，哦，那不好。然后我做了一些大演讲。有个家伙，哈克对我说话，比如“教授，什么是吸血鬼？”我做了一个演讲，比如，我做了一个一页半的关于什么是吸血鬼的演讲。
And this kid was just like not listening. So he goes, what is a vampire? And I give the whole speech. And at the end of it, he looks at me and he goes, but professor, what is a vampire? And they gave me this same cue again. Then the kid who played Dracula was this kid John Doyle who was like very like Bon Jovi based. Like his personality was Bon Jovi based. Beautiful
这个孩子只是没在听。所以他说，“什么是吸血鬼？”我做了整个演讲。在最后，他看着我，他说，“但是教授，什么是吸血鬼？”他们又给了我同样的提示。然后扮演德古拉的孩子是约翰·多伊尔，他非常像邦乔维。他的个性是基于邦乔维的。美丽。
hair. Rocker hair, beautiful hair. His mom was a hairdresser and his mom was also a professional Angeline impersonator. Side story. Anyway, we'll double back to that. We'll double back. And so John, you know, because he was like, oh, he takes rock singing lessons in New York, he was a cool guy, he was not an athlete. And so there's a scene where there's a mirror and Dracula sees the mirror and he's supposed to throw this chalice or something
头发。摇滚乐手的头发，漂亮的头发。她妈妈是理发师，也是专业的安吉丽娜·朱莉模仿者。题外话。总之，我们回头再说这个。我们回头再说。约翰呢，因为他当时就像，哦，他在纽约上摇滚歌唱课，他是个酷家伙，他不是运动员。所以有一场戏，有个镜子，德古拉看到了镜子，他本该扔掉那个圣餐杯之类的东西
and smash the mirror. And so John being not an athlete and in this open arena, I go, a mirror and then he like throws the thing, misses the mirror entirely. So then I'm like trying to improvise like what am I supposed to say? And then a full like 20 seconds later, a little techie kid comes out like in full view of the audience with a hammer from behind and smashes the mirror. Oh, one point also then the set caught on fire a little bit
然后砸碎镜子。约翰不是运动员，又在这么个开放的舞台上，我心想，镜子，然后他扔那个东西，完全没砸中镜子。所以我当时试图即兴发挥，我该说什么呢？然后过了整整20秒，一个小技术员孩子在观众完全可见的情况下，拿着锤子从后面走出来，砸碎了镜子。哦，还有一点，当时布景还着了一点火
There was like a little flashpot and the fake rocks of the castle were foam and started to catch on fire and then my dad Who was had been a fireman and does not did not fuck around? He stood up and he was like fire and we were like, okay, like he stood up in the audience this is like all act one and then Put the fire out continued. It's a longer story than you act one and then put the fire out continued as a longer story than you want it and then again the techies like there's a part where like there's a techie just like in a bay window just like in full view of the audience with a fog machine just being like knowing he's just like a total hero and then the end of the the whole thing
有个小闪光弹，城堡的假石头是泡沫做的，开始着火了，然后我爸爸，他以前是消防员，从不胡闹，他站起来喊道：“火！”我们当时就想，好吧，他在观众席站起来，这还是第一幕，然后把火扑灭了，继续演出。这故事比你想要的要长，然后技术员又来了，有一部分是一个技术员就在飘窗里，在观众完全可见的情况下，拿着烟雾机，觉得自己是个大英雄，然后整个事情的结尾
ended with like Van Helsing kills Dracula with a spike through the heart. And it was, and I'm down and I'm like acting so hard and I'm doing this whole speech. And then I just hear laughter. And I was like, this, this can't be good. This is the end of the whole play. Because again, the stage flat audience here, I was like lightning flashing. I'm killing the vampire. And I look up and just a toddler has wandered onto the stage.
以范海辛用尖桩刺穿德古拉的心脏结束。我倒在地上，演得非常卖力，还在做那段长演讲。然后我听到了笑声。我心想，这可不妙。这是整部戏的结尾。因为舞台平坦，观众就在这儿，我当时在闪电中，我正在杀死吸血鬼。我抬头一看，一个蹒跚学步的孩子走上了舞台。
No. Toward me. And that's how not scary it was. A toddler joined us. Wow. That's my story. That's hilarious. By the way, you mentioned your dad. I always think about this.
不。朝我走来。这就是它有多不吓人。一个蹒跚学步的孩子加入了我们。哇。这就是我的故事。太搞笑了。顺便说一下，你提到了你爸爸。我总是想起这个。
I met your parents a couple of times, but I remember your dad, I remember going to your wedding and we had only met a couple of times. We'd go to your wedding. Your dad described me as... He's like, that remember going to your wedding, and we had only met a couple of times, going to your wedding, your dad described me as... Oh, he's like, that guy's, Brooke's brother's handsome, right? He said, no, he's an arrow shirt, remember that? Yeah, my dad was very taken with Will, he's like, oh god, that guy looks like an arrow shirt model.
我见过你父母几次，但我记得你爸爸，我记得去参加你的婚礼，我们只见过几次面。去参加你的婚礼，你爸爸形容我……他说，那个，记得去参加你的婚礼，我们只见过几次面，去参加你的婚礼，你爸爸形容我……哦，他说，那个家伙，布鲁克的哥哥很帅，对吧？他说，不，他是“箭牌衬衫”模特，记得吗？是的，我爸爸对威尔印象很深，他说，哦天哪，那家伙看起来像个箭牌衬衫模特。
But it was very specific, do you remember arrow shirts? No, I don't remember that. Like in the Sears catalog, like, that guy's an arrow shirt, and I was like... You just made them for thick dudes? Is that what the, was it special for... I was like, in the Sears catalog, that guy's an arrow shirt, and I was like. Yeah. It was made for thick dudes? Is that what the, was it special for? Excuse me?
但这非常具体，你记得箭牌衬衫吗？不，我不记得了。就像在西尔斯目录里，那家伙是箭牌衬衫，我就说……你是专门为胖子做的吗？那是，它是专门为……我当时在西尔斯目录里，那家伙是箭牌衬衫，我就说。是的。它是为胖子做的吗？那是，它是专门为……你说什么？
Nothing. Oh no, Will was thin then, he was really thin then. I was thin then. I don't believe it. I was really. Tina, because of your theater background, would you ever want to do multicam? Now for the audience, the difference between multicam
没什么。哦不，威尔那时很瘦，他当时真的很瘦。我当时很瘦。我不信。我真的很瘦。蒂娜，因为你的戏剧背景，你有没有想过做多机位拍摄？现在给观众解释一下，多机位和单机位拍摄的区别是
and single cam is, single cam there's no audience, multicam there's a live studio audience, that's when you hear laughing like, Cheers and Will and Grace and Friends and Sunfeld and all those. Would you ever wanna do a multicam? It seems like you'd be perfect for that. Yeah, I do think it would be so fun.
单机位没有观众，多机位有现场观众，就是你听到笑声的那种，比如《干杯酒吧》、《威尔与格蕾丝》、《老友记》、《宋飞正传》等等。你有没有想过做多机位拍摄？看起来你很适合那个。是的，我觉得那会很有趣。
I feel like in some ways it's hard to, Will and Grace was one of the last ones, that was especially on NBC, they don't really do them so much anymore, and I also have reached an age where I can't really be photographed from the waist down. Yeah, not true. So.
我觉得在某些方面很难，《威尔与格蕾丝》是最后几部之一，特别是在NBC，他们现在不太拍那种了，而且我也到了一个不能从腰部以下被拍摄的年纪了。是的，那不是真的。所以。
Not true. So like, but I do think it would be fun. But wouldn't it be great to hear all that laughter through the masks? No, but, or if you don't want to be in one, just like create one and write one, I think you'd be so amazing. Are you saying that you want Tina to create
不是真的。所以，但我确实觉得那会很有趣。但隔着口罩听到所有的笑声不是很好吗？不，或者如果你不想出演，就创作并写一部，我觉得你会非常棒。你是说你想让蒂娜为你创作
a multi-cam for you? No. What about hosting a talk show? Would you ever do that Tina? It seems to me like you'd be fantastic at that. Oh thank you. I don't know if I think I'm very shy. I think to me it sounds super stressful.
一部多机位剧吗？不。主持脱口秀怎么样？你有没有想过做那个，蒂娜？在我看来你在这方面会很棒。哦，谢谢。我不知道，我觉得我很害羞。我觉得对我来说那听起来压力太大了。
I've never wanted to pursue that. I'm really shy too. Yeah, we can tell. I am. I don't like being the center of attention. Well, and also those kind of late night talk shows, like that's a grind. But I remember when you were doing 30 Rock, I mean you came off SNL, which was a grind because you were head writer and you were doing Update,
我从来没想过要追求那个。我也很害羞。是的，我们看得出来。我是。我不喜欢成为关注的焦点。嗯，而且那种深夜脱口秀，那真是苦差事。但我记得你做《我为喜剧狂》的时候，你是从《周六夜现场》出来的，那是个苦差事，因为你是首席编剧，还要做新闻播报，
and it was a lot, a lot, a lot, and especially leading right up till, you know, 2008 and everything that was going on. But I'm sorry, you were already doing 30 Rock at that point, but you were doing so much. Then you go to 30 Rock, and it just kind of amps it up even more because you're show running 30 Rock, and you're writing it all,
那真的很多，很多，很多，特别是临近2008年以及当时发生的一切。但抱歉，你那时已经在做《我为喜剧狂》了，但你做了太多事。然后你去拍《我为喜剧狂》，它变得更加激烈，因为你是《我为喜剧狂》的剧集主管，你写了所有的剧本，
and then you're starring in it as well, and having 16 hour days. So you're not pulling all-nighters every night, but you are going 18 hours or 17 hours a day. Like, that was fucking really rough right for many years in there It was insane first of all, so if you hear weird breathing sounds, it's the dog. It's not me She now has her dog her white. What is it a cockapoo? Little straight poo is a poodle straight poo
而且你还是主演，每天工作16个小时。所以你不是每天都熬通宵，但你每天要工作18或17个小时。那真的非常艰难，持续了好多年。那太疯狂了，首先，如果你听到奇怪的呼吸声，那是狗。不是我。她现在有她的狗，她的白色。是什么？一只可卡颇犬？小直毛贵宾犬，是贵宾犬直毛犬。
Yeah, looking back. I don't need to say that you look tired in those tears I just meant to know more that I know that you were very Exhausted you talked about it like you were like getting crushed. It was insane what we did I don't know we were just I was what 35 and Had some juice left and during 22 episodes and also my baby Alice was one and it was Crazy, it was crazy. It was crazy.
是的，回首往事。我不需要说你在那些照片里看起来很累，我只是想说我知道你当时非常疲惫，你谈到过，就像你快被压垮了一样。我们所做的一切太疯狂了。我不知道，我当时35岁，还有点精力，做了22集，而且我的宝宝爱丽丝才一岁，这太疯狂了，太疯狂了，太疯狂了。
Like I look back and shudder at just what we, yeah. Did you enjoy the shutdown and the pandemic to kind of recharge a little bit or did you stay super duper busy? I wouldn't say I enjoyed it. I mean, like, yeah, it's always one of those things where if you're like, oh, I'm lucky enough that nobody in my family died.
我回首往事，对我们所做的一切感到不寒而栗，是的。你享受停工和疫情期间稍微充电一下吗，还是你一直超级忙？我不会说我享受它。我的意思是，是的，这总是那种事情，如果你说，哦，我很幸运，我的家人没人去世。
So it's okay to then just quietly say say like it was nice that we were together I guess what I meant is enjoyed the the period that you could not work. Yeah, you know, yeah. Yeah nice, right? Yeah, it's kind of nice. I think like I would I'm ready to retire guys I'm ready to I've been me too By the way, I was saying the same thing and I was saying I was talking about it with with certainly with Amy too She's been feeling the same way, which is just that feeling of like, oh my God, much like you kind of did the same thing,
所以可以悄悄地说，我们在一起挺好的，我想我指的是享受那段不能工作的时期。是的，你知道，是的。是的，很好，对吧？是的，挺好的。我想我准备好退休了，伙计们，我准备好……我也是。顺便说一下，我也在说同样的话，我肯定和艾米也谈过，她也有同样的感觉，就是那种感觉，哦天哪，就像你做的一样，
had Archie went right into Parks and Rec. And those first few, when you have, both your girls have those like little babies and you're working those insane hours on those shows, it's crushing. It's like, it's soul crushing because you're not at home as much as you want to be and you've got little kids and you're trying to fuck balance it all. Right.
有了阿奇，直接去了《公园与游憩》。当你有了孩子，两个女孩都是小宝宝，你在那些节目里工作那些疯狂的时间，这太压抑了。这简直是摧毁灵魂，因为你不能像你想要的那样多待在家里，你有小孩，你试图去平衡这一切。对。
And it's all, you know, nothing compared to someone who's doing all those same work hours on a job that they hate that doesn't pay well. No, no, no. Of course it's the same as being a working parent on any job. But like just in the sense that like of any working parent, especially working mom who's working any job That's taking them long stretches, whatever it is Yeah, and of course there are a lot of people could say well you get paid really well like, okay sure But like you're still working all those hours, you know, and it's it's tough, you know, and it's hard to once you get to stop
而且，你知道，这和那些在讨厌的工作中工作同样时间却薪水不高的人相比，什么都不是。不，不，不。当然，这和任何工作岗位上的职场父母是一样的。但只是说，任何职场父母，特别是职场妈妈，做着任何需要长时间投入的工作，无论是什么。是的，当然很多人会说，好吧，你薪水很高，好吧，当然。但你仍然工作了那么长时间，你知道，这很艰难，你知道，一旦你停下来，就很难再回去。
It's hard to go back. Like I've worked on a couple things. I did a little small part in this show that Steve Martin and Marty Short have. And it was that thing of like, and your pickup is 5'10". And you're like, oh yeah, that used to be every day. Yeah. Especially for ladies, because the hair and makeup.
很难再回去。就像我做过几件事。我在史蒂夫·马丁和马蒂·肖特的那个节目里演了一个小角色。就是那种，你的接送时间是早上5点10分。你会想，哦，是的，那曾经是每天的常态。是的。特别是对女士来说，因为有发型和化妆。
People have really gotten used to working at home, too, right? And in any occupation. I wonder how that's gonna all transition back. I think- I know. I do like to go to an office. I like it too. But five days a week or would it be great
人们也真的习惯了在家工作，对吧？在任何职业中。我不知道这一切将如何过渡回来。我想——我知道。我确实喜欢去办公室。我也喜欢。但一周五天，还是说一周两天、三天会更好？我觉得那会是过渡方式。肖恩，你也喜欢去办公室吗？我喜欢。我更喜欢像老派那样，朝九晚五，在一个地方，一站式服务。杰森也喜欢那样，一站式服务，杰森也喜欢那样。我喜欢规律。杰森，我对他说，几年前我们有个小公司，我们有个共享办公室，他总是说，你这个混蛋，我们有这个地方，你从来不来。我说，好吧，我爸爸辛苦工作了40、50年，我不想那样做。你以为我为什么做我们现在做的事？就是为了不用去办公室。所以你知道我做了什么吗？我找了一张我自己的肖像，把它放在我的办公桌后面，这样他就能看着我。这是一个真实的故事，那真的就是在那个地方数回形针。是的，确实是。是的，所以蒂娜，你开玩笑说要退休，但当然你永远不会想停止写作，也永远不会想停止做那种，哦，那会……等等，蒂娜，你会做什么呢？有没有什么，想象一下，
like just two days a week, three days a week? I feel like that's gonna be the transition. Sean, you like going to the office too? I do. I prefer like the old man, nine to five, kind of one place, one stop shop. Jason likes that too one place one-stop shop Jason likes that too I like a routine Jason I said to him we had this little company a couple years ago we had this shared office and he'd always be like you fucking dick we've
就像一周只去两天、三天？我觉得这就是过渡的方式。肖恩，你也喜欢去办公室吗？我喜欢。我更像个老派的人，朝九晚五，在一个地方搞定所有事。杰森也喜欢那种在一个地方搞定所有事的感觉。杰森也喜欢那样。我喜欢规律的生活。杰森，我跟他说过，几年前我们有个小公司，共用一个办公室，他总是说，你这混蛋，我们已经
got this out and you're never in here and I go well yeah my dad worked his ass off for 40 50 years I don't want to have to do that why do you think I do what we do so that I can not go to an office so you know what I did I found a portrait of myself and I put it behind my desk so he could look at me There's that's a true story that that really was counting paper clips at that place. Yeah, it really was Yeah, so Tina like you joke about retiring But of course you're never gonna want to stop writing and you're never gonna want to stop doing that kind of oh What would so wait Tina what would you do though? Is there anything, like picture,
拿出了这个，你从来不来这儿，我说，好吧，我爸辛辛苦苦工作了四五十年，我可不想那样，你以为我为什么做我们现在做的事？就是为了不用去办公室。你知道我做了什么吗？我找了一张自己的肖像，把它放在我的办公桌后面，这样他就能看着我了。这是真的，那确实是在那个地方数回形针。是的，确实是这样。蒂娜，你开玩笑说要退休，但你当然永远不会想停止写作，也永远不会想停止做那种……等等，蒂娜，那你到底会做什么呢？有什么事吗，比如想象一下，
the girls are grown and out, and it's you and Jeff, and you're at home, and what you still would be writing, or is there something that you'd wanna be doing? I wonder, I so wonder. It's like that thing of, the improv training, right? You go back to it, and it's like,
女孩们长大了离开了，就你和杰夫，你在家里，你还会写作吗，或者有什么你想做的事吗？我很好奇，我真的很好奇。就像即兴表演训练一样，对吧？你回到它，就像，
when do you enter a scene? This is the trick the thing that trips people up. Does anyone right? Remember like when are you supposed to enter a scene and the answer is When you're needed it's the only time you're supposed to enter you're not supposed to enter because you have a funny idea You're not supposed to enter because it it's going well and you want a piece of it What about the notion of like you and Jeff just doing just globetrotting and having some wanderlust and once you guys become empty nesters just start traveling the world and knocking down and getting all cultured. Is that something that's appealing to you or are you as soft as I am and you need CNN
你什么时候进入一场戏？这是让人们绊倒的技巧。有人知道吗？记得什么时候该进入一场戏吗？答案是：当你被需要的时候。这是你唯一应该进入的时候。你不应该因为有个好笑的想法就进入。你不应该因为进展顺利，你想分一杯羹就进入。关于你和杰夫环游世界，有流浪癖，一旦你们成为空巢老人，就开始环游世界，去感受文化，这有什么吸引力吗，还是你像我一样软弱，需要CNN
and thread count? Oh yeah, I want to see a couple places, but I don't need to see everywhere. I know I'm increasingly just a homebody I know you know what I wish one of us should write is like Someone should try to be Neil Simon, right? Like someone should write a play I nominate you as if that's easy to do But like to write a comedy a hard comedy cuz I'll tell you what I go to these Broadway plays and what passes for a joke Sean right is like what passes for a joke, Sean,
和高支数床单？哦，是的，我想看几个地方，但我不需要看遍所有地方。我知道我越来越宅了。我知道，你知道我希望我们中谁能写点什么，就像有人应该尝试成为尼尔·西蒙，对吧？有人应该写一部戏，我提名你，好像这很容易做到。但写一部喜剧，一部硬核喜剧，因为我告诉你，我去百老汇看这些戏，什么能算作笑话，肖恩，对吧，什么能算作笑话，肖恩，
is like mentioning Brooklyn as a joke. Just the word. That's it. And you have to do it out, you have to play it out. Brooklyn. What about the films that Neil Simon, they adapted and became great, you know, like California Suite.
就是提到布鲁克林作为一个笑话。就那个词。就是这样。你必须把它演出来。布鲁克林。尼尔·西蒙改编的那些电影，它们成了伟大的作品，你知道，比如《加州套房》。
Yeah, California Suite. Goodbye Girl is one I like. And the Blake Edwards stuff. I mean, those big commercial films, I mean, yeah, what about those those big commercial films? I mean someone's got to write them Tina. They don't write themselves. Nobody goes to that shit I don't think they make comedy films anymore. They make like we put them on Netflix. Let's let's do that Yeah, no, man. You white I saw some poll on online today It was like if you could only live with three of these film franchises, which one would it be and it was like Marvel
是的，《加州套房》。《再见女郎》是我喜欢的。还有布莱克·爱德华兹的作品。我的意思是，那些大型商业电影，我的意思是，是的，那些大型商业电影怎么样？我的意思是总得有人写它们，蒂娜。它们不会自己写出来。没人去看那些垃圾。我觉得他们不再拍喜剧电影了。他们把它们放在Netflix上。让我们做那个吧。是的，不，伙计。你白……我今天在网上看到一个民意调查，就像如果你只能和这三个电影系列一起生活，会是哪一个，就像漫威
You could only live with three of these film franchises. Which one would it be? And it was like Marvel, Star Wars, Harry Potter, and I was like, wait, that's what it's become? That's it? Those are the films? Fuck that, man. And nobody's funny. This is crazy.
你只能和这三个电影系列一起生活。会是哪一个？就像漫威、星球大战、哈利·波特，我就想，等等，这就是它变成的样子吗？就是这样？那些就是电影？去他的，伙计。而且没人好笑。这太疯狂了。
I can't wait for the letters and the comments. Oh, nobody's funny anymore? Yeah, okay, yeah, you're hilarious. I love it. Bring it on. I can't wait for you. But you're not saying that. You're saying that comedies are not in the theaters anymore, really.
我等不及那些信件和评论了。哦，没人好笑了？是的，好吧，是的，你太搞笑了。我喜欢。放马过来吧。我等不及了。但你不是那个意思。你是说喜剧不再在电影院里了，真的。
Yes, that's what I'm saying. Nobody's making comedy films. No one's gonna make, you know, the in-laws now, the original in-laws. No, no. Nobody's gonna make. No, nobody's making, you can't make Rushmore today. Nobody's making Rushmore.
是的，这就是我的意思。没人拍喜剧电影。没人会拍，你知道，现在的《姻亲》，原版的《姻亲》。不，不。没人会拍。不，没人拍，你今天拍不出《青春年少》。没人拍《青春年少》。
You'd make it for Netflix, I guess. But I'm fine watching it at home on my couch. I don't need to drive to a theater to see that, right? I mean, I'd go to a theater to see some big, huge format, right? A big IMAX thing or something. You come ask them. Is that Penelope? Come ask them. What's your question?
我想你会为Netflix拍它。但我很高兴在家里沙发上看它。我不需要开车去电影院看那个，对吧？我的意思是，我会去电影院看一些大格式的，对吧？一个巨大的IMAX之类的东西。你来问他们。那是佩内洛普吗？来问他们。你的问题是什么？
How much longer? Okay, we're almost done. Sorry, we're almost done. We're gonna wrap it up now. Your agent looks real young. Yeah, we are past our hour here. I know. We've been taking up way too much of your time I'm sorry that we're keeping you from the fact because I want to keep you on I want I just want your opinion on everything I feel like anytime I get your opinion. It feels like it's really the right one
还要多久？好吧，我们快结束了。抱歉，我们快结束了。我们现在要收尾了。你的经纪人看起来很年轻。是的，我们已经超过一小时了。我知道。我们占用了你太多时间，我很抱歉我们让你……因为我想留住你，我只是想要你对每件事的看法。我觉得每当我得到你的看法，感觉那真的是正确的。
Yeah, so that's why we've been keeping you around but opinions are all I have anymore. No, it's so good We're gonna dismiss you but we're gonna reserve the right to call you back with any questions we have. That's right. Anytime, guys. Oh, you're the best. Thank you so much for taking your time to do this. I love you, Tina Fey. Saturday, you're the best. I love all three of you. Love you, Tina. Go have fun with the rest of your day with that sweet girl.
是的，这就是为什么我们一直留着你，但观点是我现在唯一拥有的东西。不，这太好了。我们要让你走了，但我们保留随时打电话给你询问任何问题的权利。没错。随时，伙计们。哦，你们是最棒的。非常感谢你花时间做这个。我爱你，蒂娜·菲。周六，你们是最棒的。我爱你们三个。爱你，蒂娜。去和那个甜美的女孩享受你剩下的时光吧。
Oh, yeah. Hey! Okay, we love you. Go be a good boy, mom. Love you, Tina. Thank you. Thanks, Tina. Bye, bye, bye. Bye, base. Boy, just another
哦，是的。嘿！好吧，我们爱你。去当个好孩子，妈妈。爱你，蒂娜。谢谢。谢谢，蒂娜。再见，再见，再见。再见，基地。天哪，又一个
She wanted to get off there at the end. Do you think she gave a cue to Penelope to come in and say okay now this is the time where I need you to No, she'd had it in her mind. Everybody knows who she is. Everybody knows how brilliant she is. Everybody knows. Everybody's a fan. It seems like that's the one person everybody can agree on right? That's oh my god. She's I would like to find the person that that doesn't like Tina Fey like who yeah who's who's that how could you possibly not yeah I know she's the most she's just so freaking funny she's such an unbelievable writer and a great joke writer I mean just the funniest doesn't
她想在最后离开那里。你觉得她给了佩内洛普一个暗示，让她进来并说，好吧，现在是我需要你的时候吗？不，她心里已经有了。每个人都知道她是谁。每个人都知道她有多聪明。每个人都知道。每个人都是粉丝。看起来那是每个人都能达成一致的人，对吧？那是，哦天哪。她是……我想找到那个不喜欢蒂娜·菲的人，就像谁，是的，谁是那个，你怎么可能不喜欢，是的，我知道她是，她太搞笑了，她是一位令人难以置信的作家和伟大的笑话作家，我的意思是，最搞笑的，不
take herself or anything too seriously the funniest joke on everything you know it's it's, it's intimidating. It must be for you guys. A great leader, seems like a great leader. Incredible leader. I'm very drawn to her. It was great. Sean, you were on 30 Rock a few times or once?
把自己或任何事情看得太重，关于每件事最搞笑的笑话，你知道，这，这，这很吓人。对你们来说一定很吓人。一位伟大的领导者，看起来像一位伟大的领导者。不可思议的领导者。我被她深深吸引。这太棒了。肖恩，你上过《我为喜剧狂》几次，还是只有一次？
Just once, the finale of that first season. Will, you were on it a bunch of times, weren't you? I guess. Well, that's what the four Emmy nominations tell me but you know. Wait what? Come on. It doesn't matter. Oh. It doesn't matter. Wait a second. Is that true? Is that true? Honestly. Were you on for four seasons? But did you get nominated? Four times yeah yeah. Congratulations. Yeah four. Congratulations. Wait so guests so so you do you did four episodes you got nominated for all four? No I did more
只有一次，第一季的结局。威尔，你上过很多次，对吧？我想是吧。嗯，这就是四项艾美奖提名告诉我的，但你知道。等等，什么？得了吧。没关系。哦。没关系。等一下。那是真的吗？那是真的吗？老实说。你拍了四季吗？但你被提名了吗？四次，是的，是的。恭喜。是的，四次。恭喜。等等，所以嘉宾，所以你拍了四集，你四集都被提名了？不，我拍了更多
than four episodes. I did a bunch. I did like, the first season I did one or two. It was not their first season. It was like, there was something. So do you want me to do an impression of your mom really quick? Yeah, go ahead. Yeah. Well, it would have been more impressive if you won.
超过四集。我拍了很多。我拍了，第一季我拍了一两集。那不是他们的第一季。就像，有那么回事。所以你想让我快速模仿一下你妈妈吗？是的，来吧。是的。嗯，如果你赢了会更令人印象深刻。
That's true. That's very true. Should be much more impressive if I had won. Yeah. God, I. She's listening. We can cut that if you. No, we can keep it. You know, the first time Jason, you know this story
那是真的。那非常真实。如果我赢了会更令人印象深刻。是的。天哪，我。她在听。我们可以剪掉那个，如果你。不，我们可以保留。你知道，第一次，杰森，你知道这个故事
The four we were coming back the rest of development had won the comedy the Emmy for best comedy and 2004 whatever that was and the next day It was that was a Sunday night the next Monday. We had to be at work early You and I were in that scene. Do you remember we had the Emmy those guys Chuck Martin brought his on set We were so excited that we won, improbably, because we were such a low rated show. And I'm driving to the Fox lot from Venice,
四个人，我们回来的时候，《发展受阻》赢得了喜剧类艾美奖，2004年还是什么时候，第二天，那是周日晚上，接下来的周一。我们必须早点上班。你和我都在那场戏里。你记得吗，我们有艾美奖，那些家伙，查克·马丁把它带到了片场。我们非常兴奋我们赢了，不可思议地，因为我们是一个收视率很低的节目。我正从威尼斯开车去福克斯片场，
and my mom calls, and it was like 6 a.m. LA time, and I've been up until three, because we were so excited. It's like, oh my God, did you watch, did you see the Emmys last night? No, we won, and she goes, I did. Now your sister is going through and then just completely. Oh! Oh!
我妈妈打电话来，当时是洛杉矶时间早上6点，我一直醒到三点，因为我们太兴奋了。就像，哦天哪，你看了吗，你昨晚看艾美奖了吗？不，我们赢了，她说，我看了。现在你妹妹正在经历，然后就完全。哦！哦！
Oh! Oh! And I was like, okay. It was a very sort of Canadian, like the whole idea is always like, don't get too big for yourself. Right. You know, and don't like,
哦！哦！我就想，好吧。这是一种非常加拿大的方式，就像整个想法总是，不要太自以为是。对吧。你知道，不要像，
oh, you think that you're better than anybody else? Like, I guess I don't, I'm sorry, I don't. I think I'm worse. And they're like, there we go, that's more like it. You know the idea, have you ever heard the story about the two lobster fishermen, one Canadian, one American, who are walking down the road, and the American lobster fisherman says to the Canadian,
哦，你以为你比别人强吗？就像，我想我没有，抱歉，我没有。我觉得我更糟。他们就像，这就对了，那更像样。你知道那个想法吗，你听过关于两个龙虾渔夫的故事吗，一个加拿大人，一个美国人，他们走在路上，美国龙虾渔夫对加拿大人说，
he says, notice that you don't have a lid on your lobster pot there, boy, aren't you worried that your lobster's gonna get out? And the Canadian says, no, these here are Canadian lobsters. If one of them tries to get out, the other ones will pull them back down. That's Canada. That's Canada. That's what I grew up in. Oh bless.
他说，注意到你的龙虾笼上没有盖子，伙计，你不担心你的龙虾会跑出来吗？加拿大人说，不，这些是加拿大龙虾。如果其中一个试图爬出来，其他的会把它拉回去。这就是加拿大。这就是加拿大。这就是我成长的环境。哦，天哪。
And I love Canada. I love it to death. And I grew up like that too. It's a very, there's a very sort of, anyway. I don't know why I'm on this. Speaking of Canada, have you given any thoughts? I imagine you're gonna book the guest for our for our Toronto stop for our for our tour our tour Which listener it does look like it's firming up
我爱加拿大。我爱死它了。我也那样长大。这非常，有一种非常，总之。我不知道为什么我在说这个。说到加拿大，你考虑过吗？我想你会为我们的多伦多站预订嘉宾，为我们的巡演，我们的巡演。哪个听众，看起来确实在确定了
It does look like we're gonna we're gonna actually do this and we're gonna go to a few cities Just inside the new year just inside the new year 2022 and we're starting the tour in Toronto. Is that right, eh? We can say that, yeah. Yeah. And then some New York and some Boston, some Chicago, some Madison, some LA. Is that right? I think that's right, yeah.
看起来我们确实要这样做，我们要去几个城市，就在新年刚过，就在2022年新年刚过，我们从多伦多开始巡演。是这样吗，嗯？我们可以这么说，是的。是的。然后是一些纽约，一些波士顿，一些芝加哥，一些麦迪逊，一些洛杉矶。是这样吗？我想是这样，是的。
So who would we, can we, will you try to... I have a couple people in mind that I want to have for Toronto. You know, I know that Chicago... We should start taking suggestions for guests. Yeah, we should. That's a good should idea just saying the expression tap link in bio Does that mean anything tap link in bio? Who's who's Lincoln bio? That's what that's what you say on like Instagram You know, oh tap link in your link in bio, you know what else they say sometimes on Instagram No, don't don't you do it. Not yet. we're still talking. We're still talking Jesus fucking Chris
那么我们会，我们可以，你会尝试……我有几个人选，我想让他们参加多伦多站。你知道，我知道芝加哥……我们应该开始接受嘉宾建议。是的，我们应该。那是个好主意，只是说“点击简介链接”这个表达，那意味着什么，点击简介链接？谁是简介链接？那是你在Instagram上说的，你知道，哦，点击你的简介链接，你知道他们有时在Instagram上还说什么吗？不，别，别那样做。还没。我们还在谈。我们还在谈，该死的耶稣
Are you get so excited when he figures out a pie perfect? I know it would have been perfect But we need we have a few more things that we need to do about the tour to talk okay because the tour is becoming A reality yes Sean do you have a person in mind for Chicago? I do I have several but I don't want to say them out Loud yeah, don't say them out loud yet. Yeah, how are we gonna decide who's booking what city? Well, why don't we well here we have to do dibs, and I wanna do dibs, you ready? Toronto and Wisconsin, Madison. Oh, you want Madison.
当你弄清楚一个派完美时，你是不是很兴奋？我知道那会很完美，但我们需要，我们还有几件事需要做，关于巡演要谈，好吧，因为巡演正在成为现实。是的，肖恩，你心里有芝加哥的人选吗？我有，我有几个，但我不想大声说出来。是的，先别大声说出来。是的，我们怎么决定谁预订哪个城市？嗯，为什么我们不，这里我们必须做“先占权”，我想做先占权，准备好了吗？多伦多和威斯康星，麦迪逊。哦，你想要麦迪逊。
You're gonna take. I want Madison. Even though it's my sister. Wait, but are we going to Madison strictly to see Sean's niece, nephew? My sister is through fucking idiot. And how could Tracy be his nephew, man? I've met a couple of Tracy dudes. Yeah, I do too.
你要拿走。我想要麦迪逊。尽管那是我妹妹。等等，但我们去麦迪逊是为了看肖恩的侄女、侄子吗？我妹妹是个该死的白痴。特雷西怎么可能是他的侄子，伙计？我见过几个叫特雷西的家伙。是的，我也见过。
You have to, yeah, yeah. But all these guests need to be sort of germane to the location, yes? That's right, that's right. That's the whole idea is we're gonna have guests who are germane, hopefully like a very sort of organic, not shoehorned in pick. So think about it.
你必须，是的，是的。但所有这些嘉宾都需要与地点相关，对吧？没错，没错。这就是整个想法，我们要有相关的嘉宾，希望像一种非常有机的方式，而不是硬塞进去的选择。所以考虑一下。
I think that what we gotta do is though, we gotta make sure. Here it comes. No, why? You have a bye? No, I can't, but for the tour though, if you wanna talk about the tour, I can't wait. No, I'm not saying that there's rules.
我想我们必须做的是，我们必须确保。它来了。不，为什么？你有再见？不，我不能，但对于巡演，如果你想谈论巡演，我等不及了。不，我不是说有规则。
I'm not saying that there are rules to this. I'm just saying that you have to check the. Bye, y'all! So bad. Okay, goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不是说这有规则。我只是说你必须检查。再见，各位！太糟糕了。好吧，再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。